the owner of a restaurant wants to find
out more about where his patrons are
coming from one day he decided to gather
data about the distance in miles that
people commuted to get to his restaurant
people reported the following distances
traveled so here all the distances
traveled he wants to create a graph that
helps him understand the spread of
distances is the key word the spread of
distances and the median distance and
the median distance that people traveled
or that people travel what kind of graph
should he create so the the answer of
what kind of graph he should create that
might be a little bit more
straightforward than the actual creation
of the graph which we will also do but
he's trying to visualize the spread of
information and at the same time he
wants the median so what graph captures
both of that information well a box and
whisker plot
so let's actually try to draw a box and
whisker plot and to do that we need to
come up with the median and we'll also
see the median of the two halves of the
data as well and whenever we're trying
to take the median of something it's
really helpful to order our data so
let's start off by attempting to order
our data so what is the smallest number
here well let's see there's one two so
let me mark it off and then we have
another two another two so we got all
the twos then we have this three then we
have this three I think we got all the
threes then we have that four then we
have this four do we have any fives no
do we have any sixes yet we have that
six and that looks like the only six any
sevens yep we have this 7 right over
here and I just realized that I missed
this one so let me put the one at the
beginning of our set so I got that one
right over there actually there's two
ones I missed both of them so both of
those ones are right over there so I
have one two three four s no fives this
is one six
there was one seven there's one eight
right over here one eight
and then let's see any 9s no 9s any tens
yep there's a 10 and the 11s we have an
11 right over there any 12s nope 13 14
then we have a 15 then we have a 20 and
then a 22 so we've ordered all our data
now it should be relatively
straightforward to find the middle of
our data the median so how many data
points do we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 so the middle
number is going to be a number that has
eight numbers larger than it and eight
numbers smaller than it so let's think
about it 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so the number 6
here is larger than 8 of the values and
if I did the calculations right it
should be smaller than 8 of the values 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so it is indeed it is
indeed the median now when we take a
box-and-whisker when we were trying to
construct a box and whisker plot the
convention is ok we have our median and
it's essentially dividing our data into
two sets now let's take the median of
each of those sets and the convention is
to take our median out and have the sets
that are left over sometimes people
leave it in but the standard convention
take this median out and now look
separately at this set and look
separately at this set so if we look at
this first the bottom half of our
numbers essentially what's the median of
these numbers well we have one two three
four five six seven eight data points so
we're actually going to have two middle
numbers so the two middle numbers are is
this 2 and this 3 3 numbers less than
these 2 3 numbers greater than it and so
when we're looking for a median you have
two middle numbers we take the mean of
these two numbers so halfway in between
two and three is 2.5 or you say 2 plus 3
is 5 divided by 2 is 2.5 so here here we
have a median of this bottom half of 2.5
and then the middle of the top half once
again we have 8 data points
so our middle two numbers our middle two
numbers are going to be this 11 and this
14 and so if we want to take the mean of
these two numbers
11 plus 14 is 25 halfway in between the
two is 12 point 5 so 12 point 5 is
exactly halfway between 11 and 14 and
now we've figured out all of the
information we need to actually plot or
actually create or actually draw our box
and whisker plot so let me draw a number
line let me draw a number line so my
best attempt at a number line so that's
my number line and let's say that this
right over here is 0 I need to make sure
I get all the way up to 22 or beyond 22
so let's say that's 0 let's say this is
5 this is 10 that could be 15 and that
could be 20 this could be 25 it could
keep going 30 maybe 35 so the first
thing we might want to think about
there's several ways to draw it we want
to think about the box part of the box
and whisker essentially represents the
middle half of our data so it's
essentially trying to represent trying
to represent this data right over here
so the data between the two between the
medians of the two halves so this is a
part that we would represent attempt to
represent with the box so we would start
right over here at this lower this this
2.5 this is essentially separating the
first quartile from the second quartile
the first quarter of our numbers from
the second quarter of our numbers so
let's put it right over here so this is
2.5 2.5 is halfway between 0 and 5 so
that's 2.5 and then up here we have 12.5
and 12.5 is right over let's see this is
10 10 so this right over here would be
this halfway between well halfway
between 10 and 15 is 12.5 so let me do
this so this is 12.5 right over here
12.5
so that separates the third quartile
from the fourth quartile and then our
boxes everything in between so this is
literally the middle half of our numbers
the middle half of our numbers and we'd
want to show where the actual median is
and that was actually one of the things
we wanted to be able to think about in
our original when when when the owner of
the restaurant wanted to think about how
far people are traveling from so the
median is six so we can plot it right
over here so if this this right over
here looks this is about six so that is
we doing that same pink color so this
right over here is 6 and then the
whiskers of the box and whisker plot
essentially show us the range of our
data and so let me do that I could do
this in a different color that I haven't
used yet I'll do this in orange so
essentially if we want to see look the
numbers go all the way up to 22 so they
go all the way up to so let's say that
this is 22 right over here our numbers
go all the way up to 22 our numbers go
all the way up to 22 and they go as low
as 1 so they go 1 is right about here
they go as low we label that so that's 1
and they go as low as 1 so there you
have it we have our box and whisker plot
and you can see if you have a plot like
this just visually you can immediately
see ok what is the median it's the
middle of the box essentially it shows
you the middle half so it shows you how
far they're spread or kind of where the
the meet of the spread is and then it
shows well beyond that we have the range
that goes well beyond that it goes or or
how far the total spread of our data is
so this gives a pretty good sense of
both the median and the spread of our
data